- Les Canadiens ne peuvent plus
payer mais le gouvernement...onu
pour sa maîtrise des réseaux
sociaux et ses vidéos incisives.
- Pas d'augmentation de taxes,
pas d'augmentation d'impôts sone
favorite se retourne
soudainement contre lui.
Le réseau Global a révélé que
depuis quatre ans,lateforme Youe
sont associées à un mot-clic
controversé : "Men going
their own way", qu'on pourrait
suivent leur propre chemin".
Un mouvement anti-féministe
et misogyne.liste,
"Décrypteurs"
- "Men going their own way",
c'est une sorte d'idéologieet pl
extrême associée au mouvement
masculiniste. Donc la croyance
centrale, c'est que les femmnt .
- Le mot-clic, qu'on appelle
une balise intégrée, n'est pas
visible aux internautes.on va vs
le code HTML du site web
de YouTube, on peut voir...
- Mais se trouve dde programmat.
- L'effet est que
vidéo-là va être sensiblements s
qui effectuent dess
à propos de ce mouvement-là.
des vidéos, mais jeudi après-
midi, il était encé
à la chaîne YouTube
de Pierre Poilievre.
"Men going their own way".
- L'affa déclenché
une tempête aux Communes.
- Take responsibility
- Les rôles ont carrément
rsés à la période
des questions. Pierre Poilievre
a été forcé de s'expliquer.
(en anglais)
le mouvement et a assuré avoir
corrigé le problème quand
il a appris son existence.
Son équipe affirme
Ses adversaires n'en croient
rien et passent à.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
d'aller chercher des groupes
anti-femmes, misogynes,
extrémistes de droite pour
avancer son agenda politique.
députée, PLC Hochelaga, Québec
- Ça me semble être
une stratégie déli
chercher des créneaux d'appuis.
- "C'est choquant et dangereux",
dit cette ministre libérale.
- Going to a meeting, thank you.
- Les déient pas de détour
pour défendre leur chef.
Celui-ci parle de foutaise. Less
démontrent que Pierre Poilievre
est plus populairees.
Cette controverse n'a rien
pour aid
cette tendance.
Ici Louis Blouin,